Fritzie reached out to de pallone former
baseball umpire and I believe he had
that same call back in 1987 the NLCS
Giants and the Cardinals Dave thanks for
joining us on short notice can you walk
us through the play last night if you
were the home plate umpire what would
you have seen and what would you have
said well the end first thanks for
having me on and it's always a pleasure
to talk to you as far as if you watch
the entire play the umpire got in the
correct position if you notice he stood
right on the foul line and watch the
play happen and they have that 45 foot
Lane is what it's called or block and if
you know it's not there just to be
pretty it's there for a reason it's a
rule that the runner must have one foot
in that box and the other foot on the
white line at least both feet are
supposed to be in but they consider it
in the box if he has one foot on the
white line and the other foot in the box
and he's supposed to run down that line
one thing that was interesting that you
talked about John Smoltz he made a
comment last night maybe it was heard by
most people maybe it wasn't but he said
that he is taught as a pitcher to throw
the ball at the batter when he's running
down the line because he will get that
call if he's out of the box
mmm and that's what happened last night
and and he was not at any time in that
box never it was that call correct call
there was just no question about what
the call should have been and if he had
not made that call it would have been
the wrong call and it could have really
even though it didn't change the game
because of the whole line so forth and
so on it could have changed the game and
the the call was correct you know
there's been a lot of talk about the
umpires missing balls and strikes so
forth and so on
yes I have seen that but that call was
absolutely correct how many times in the
course of a game do we see a runner
running inside not probably not probably
never but just going down the first base
line Dave it happens
time oh wait maybe I misunderstood maybe
I misunderstood your question how many
times are they in the blocks at how many
times are they out of the box I'm sorry
how many times has a lot like running to
first base how many times do you see a
runner who's on a little he's inside the
foul line probably 95% of the time
they're inside yeah they're never in
that box never in that box okay but we
want call again what we don't call it
because they don't usually interfere
with the play you know I mean if they
were to hit the pyramid to play if they
if they hinder the first baseman from
catch you catch in the throw from the
picture or the catcher yes if the if the
ball is hit if the catcher or the
pitcher hits the the base rhyme with the
ball then you 99.9 percent of the time
they will be called for it what do you
think I'm going to happen how can you
call it what what brought about the
interference the throw or the runner
because if you think about it the
picture threw the ball right at first
base and the runner is outside that box
and if you notice the runner ran into
the first baseman and knocked off his
glove as the ball was hitting them and
if he had been on the opposite the right
side of the bag that would not have
happened and actually it was a better
throw maybe you know to the outside to
the infield side he probably would have
been you know most likely but I'm not
sure but as far as when it happens and
how it happens
like you said he'd hardly ever see
anybody running in the box but if they
have pictures and pitches would be use
the rule to their advantage all they
have to do is throw the ball at the back
of the runner and most likely he's going
to be called out because that is a rule
that's gonna rule forever
should it be interviewed should it be
reviewable no no that wasn't reviewable
because they they said last night it
wasn't reviewable and I didn't
understand why they were review
honorable because of the fact that was a
judgment call I mean I don't know all
the ins and outs of
what they say that is reviewable now but
they even announced last night that
wasn't reviewable I mean I the same play
happened to me in 87 and when wedding
Herzl came out I explained the situation
what's right away because he understood
it and it's over 30 years now since I
made that call it's the same call famous
that play the the batter was Coleman and
he got the guy the third he went to
second but got the first called him up
was a big play in the seventh inning of
the game and it truly is it's a crucial
call and you know John Smoltz made it
perfect last night he made the perfect
analysis you know throw the ball they
were taught to throw the ball at runners
back and and the pitchers and catchers
would do that more did start running in
that box because they know that they
could hold out yeah I think it even if
Trey Turner is running correctly that
ball is maybe not going to get caught or
you're not going to make that play at
first I thought that the play created
all of the drama and I don't think what
Trey Turner did was egregious I just
don't think it wasn't necessarily
I'd just think that the the throw itself
Dave created the controversy and what
Turner did I've seen far more egregious
running in a basin I probably said right
on that analogy but you know if you
really want to go what I mean what the
rulebook says you know that's what the
rules are for them not just to ignore
them you can't ignore them I mean you
know they're there for a reason and that
reason came up last night and you know
my my phone and my texting last night
was off the hook last night people
asking me what did you think was so
close and so on
and I had my answer already for
everybody just copied and pasted to copy
the page it was no problem whatsoever I
didn't see any problem whatsoever with
that call and you know I felt bad that
Martinez got thrown out but I probably
would have thought about a little faster
I've been working on my strike three
call Oh have you yeah love to hear all
right you ready I'm ready now too long
way too long way too long that's it
that's it you need wait give me yours
again you said didn't like dr. rennet
like you know how you said that's ready
it's just like like he's like ten
minutes come on I don't know how many
letters are in your strike call like you
just said hey PST are you saying I think
you're saying go sit down like Dave good
to talk to you again thank you we'll
wait till there's another controversy
and then we'll call you again very good
ha that's a day plum former baseball
player for more Dan Patrick show tune in
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]